I think an artist and activist in a way
otherwise usually decoration and design
I guess
I always say that Arabic script you know
reaches your your heart you know like in
your soul before it touches your eyes as
an artist have the responsibility to
bring people together and not to divide
people so that's why I try to always
make sure that what I'm writing as this
not double meaning but make people think
you know I share about the human
condition
if you paint I don't like figurative
stuff or if you write stuff you need to
make sure that it's not just it'll be
beautiful but you need to inspire people
to allowed to move into something